good morning Hank it's Tuesday happy
beats a mess underneath my pizza John
sweatshirt I've got my pizza John galaxy
check this means that I'm wearing my
face atop my face atop my torso which is
a little bit weird but anyway Hank I
have breaking news and it comes from my
last video nerdfighter Matt wrote I
haven't liked your beard for years I
like it now which came right on the
heels of you texting me Hank good video
and I finally like your beard like all
of this can only mean one thing it's
time to shave the beard movie she's back
all right Hank time to move on to the
serious business of today's video but
first I must ask you not to make fun of
me you know this is a gift for you
today's video comes to you in four parts
part one Hank yesterday you said that
the project for awesome begins at
midnight on December 11th that was a lie
in fact it begins at noon Eastern Time
on December 11th that's when the project
for awesome livestream will begin it's
also when you should upload your project
for awesome videos nerdfighters remember
your project files and videos could
raise money for your favorite charities
for those who know another project for
awesome is an annual charity event
organized by nerdfighteria actually heck
talked about it in his last video you
should just watch that because it's very
funny and also he's got some dance moves
in it that are equal to or maybe
slightly better than Drake's fart do in
addition to all these pizzas on t-shirts
only being available for pre-order
during Pizza Mist there's lots of other
Pizza John gear that's only available
during pizza most including shoestrings
also a travel mug and many other items I
can't decide what is my favorite but I
think it might be that the PISA shirt
this is leaning the meaning face of Pisa
part 3 a story from my recent past so I
got I like to drop names or anything but
after I got meningitis last year Bill
Gates sent me a get-well-soon orchid it
was a really thoughtful gesture and I
really appreciated it so anyway recently
we had a dinner party at our house and
someone said I love your orchid and I
said I know it's beautiful right not to
name-drop or anything but Bill Gates
gave it to me and everyone was like oh
that's very impressive of Bill Gates
orchid except Sarah was looking at me
kind of funny so I was like what and
she's like god it's nothing and I was
like what and she was like well I mean
that's not Bill Gates's orchid and I was
like what Bill Gates is orchid and she
was like Bill Gates's orchid died we got
this orchid at Trader Joe's so it was a
little bit embarrassed but you know I'm
not a particularly observant person when
it comes to orchids so anyway
flash-forward a couple weeks my friend
Stuart seen here with his wife and Marie
and
orchid in question brings me a gift and
I unwrap it and it's a little plaque for
my orchid to remind me you know that's
not Bill Gates's orchid anyway Hank what
I'm saying is that I have great friends
this is a double bragging story because
first I'm bragging about the Bill Gates
orchid and then I'm bragging about how
great my friends are but my point is
that Stewart and Henry were part of an
art assignment we just did which was
also a dinner party you can watch that
video over at the art assignment Clark
for sometimes I glanced at myself in the
viewfinder and I cannot believe that I'm
going to upload this to YouTube that is
not part 4 I have to say the mustache is
kind of growing on me actually Hank both
literally and figuratively if this video
is just to send it into a series of dad
jokes part four is that I'm going to do
a question Tuesday on Thursday because
it seems like the right time to do it
Hank
so nerdfighters I need your questions
preferably brief ones in comments Hank
I must say the resemblance is uncanny
happy pizza miss I will see you tomorrow
PS I just went upstairs and saw Alice
and she looked at me for a long time and
then said daddy what on your face and I
said oh it's a mustache and she said a
must ask and I said I actually already
made that joke